oh my god you grew up hey your dad told
me that you're thinking about coming up
here for college exciting yeah maybe you
new to town I'm visiting my aunt
I'm Katie sit hey I get off in about ten
minutes if you want to I don't know go
for a walk or something okay your aunt
cool yeah she is a writer you write a
lot about religion you really believe in
like a heaven and hell and all that I
believe in grace I believe in a complete
meaning somewhere you really think we're
gonna see my mom again
do you ever have sex sorry is that okay
yeah sure I do really well with who
distracted think it Miranda what and I'm
trying to make it's been forever hasn't
it that's how you a super I I don't want
to have sex with you what is that weird
so you were both married to men I was a
widow betty was married Gotti Boris so
you liked it and you did are you asking
if we liked it so it is not a handicap
to have one thing but not another we are
different shapes and ways and our
happiness is unique
so what are you into everything
[Music]